this is cook your ass off celebrity chef
Richard Blais whose the cooking
competition will incredible cooking and
healthy food fight to coexist
series premiere Sunday December 1st at 7
p.m. on up wave on HLN
three chefs each week battle it out for
a $50,000 grand prize to transform
unhealthy food into healthy food you can
check that out
December 1st at 7 p.m. on up wave on the
HLN Network let me know I sent you
so there's a meth lab in Homefront and
as I was watching it all I could think
of was that if Walter White from
Breaking Bad saw that meth lab he would
have an absolute conniption I mean there
was a lot more than just one fly in this
thing trust me
Homefront stars Jason Statham James
Franco wino de Rider Kate Bosworth and
Clancy Brown it's also written by
Sylvester Stallone that's right rocky
himself wrote this movie I mean this
movie Jason Statham plays this guy named
Phil broker
he's an ex-dea cop who after a bad drug
bust decided to leave the force he moves
himself and his daughter to this very
quiet town hoping to escape some of
these problems from the past when the
past catches up to him when he runs into
this guy James Franco his character's
name is Gator boudin I really like that
name
this guy is a ruthless meth dealer and
for various reasons a giant grudge match
develops amongst Jason Statham and
pretty much everyone in this town the
home front isn't really a movie I was
dying to see but I do like Jason Statham
he's a badass he's a likeable actor he's
just not a character actor he basically
plays the same character over and over
again but he is good at what he does and
he does it well in homefront and he's
likable in this movie he's fun to watch
he kicks ass that's what he does
he's good at it here I think that
confuse me was James Franco as the
villain because yes he has played drug
dealers before and movies like spring
breakers very well in fact but it just
seemed odd that he would be the villain
in a Jason Statham movie believe it or
not though I actually really enjoyed him
in the role I thought he added a lot to
the role he was pretty funny in the
movie too he had a good introduction but
after that introduction it wasn't as
good anymore and I'll explain why this
movie isn't really that great in my
opinion for one this is a type of movie
that needs to embrace what it is and
what it is is a very cliched movie that
is filled to the brim with genre
conventions you know basically
everything that's going to happen at
some point the little girl will be in
jeopardy that's obvious and I get it and
it works in that way you know you can
watch a movie and the pieces fall into
order and you know okay I want to see
Jason Statham punch this kind of face
that guy needs to get punched in the
face I hope he gets punched in the face
oh good he got punched in the face
that's Jason state of the movie it can
be entertaining but really how far does
that nerd
go because this movie tries to be a
little more serious and I think it
deserves to be the best parts of this
movie are when it embraces what it is
and that is a silly action movie like
James Franco's introduction to this
movie wielding a baton saying what his
name is in this very over exaggerated
southern accent it's great like that's
where this movie has cool elements to it
is when it understands what it is
whatever it tries to be more serious
than it really deserves to be is when it
kind of gets into the melodrama area
Kate Bosworth and Wynonna Ryder both
play very convincing crack whores it's
it's what they are in the movie that's
their characters and they're very good
at it they they definitely come off that
way the performances in this movie
aren't bad at all in fact the little
girl Jason Statham's daughter in the
movie she was really good too actually
also along the way I seem to think that
the movie was directed by two different
people because there were some shots
that are nice and flowing and panoramic
and wide and very steady and then
whenever someone gets punched in the
face which as I already said is what you
go to adjacent state the movie for it's
like he's got to shake the camera up and
cut it all over the place and I have a
cut here and a cut here it's not as bad
as say Alex Cross which is the worst
fight scene I have ever seen in a movie
it wasn't like hair-pulling ly awful but
it's there and I'm like does this movie
really have to look the same way as all
these other movies do nowadays can't
they just pull out when they film a
fight scene anymore Jason Statham he can
do his own stunts he does them well you
don't need to try to make it seem harder
than it is he's good at it make it look
better there's also a romance in the
film that develops along the way and
then it just fizzles and you're like
what happened with that there are some
good scenes where Jason Statham goes and
visits certain people in the town he's
like I'm going to tell you about this
and you get to listen to me I'm gonna
kick your ass otherwise like stuff like
that basically and that's my horrible
Jason Statham imitation but I try it
okay I try sometimes I can do there are
some interesting scenes like that where
there are two characters just facing off
and you're like this is cool I want more
of this and those are the serious
elements where the film works where it
understands that brawny testosterone
that Statham offers in his movies and
that's what he's best at when the film
works at those strengths it's enjoyable
to watch there are some fun action
scenes in the film even though it's a
little too shaky but my biggest problem
with this movie is that the entire film
feels impossible if every character in
this town didn't have such a problem
holding grudges I mean
really where the entire plot of this
film progresses is the fact that one
character gets really mad about
something incidental and calls someone
else and says I'm mad do something about
it and that guy calls somebody else and
says I'm mad do something about it
because I'm too lazy to do something
about it and you're more of a bad person
than me so you do that thing that I
don't want to do because I'm mad at that
guy and then eventually it's just this
overblown situation and yes there are
times in the movie were various good
characters worn state of this town holds
grudges and this town holds grudges near
like yes I get it this is a grudge
holding town but the entire movie
wouldn't happen and it would just end
two credits if some character was like
you know what I get it
okay sorry have a nice day bye and then
the whole movie would be over
nevertheless it's an okay watch I didn't
hate myself during the movie I wasn't
bored I enjoyed certain scenes of it if
it came on cable one day maybe check it
out otherwise probably not worth your
time in the theaters I'm gonna give
Homefront a C+ so guys a request that
I've been getting a lot is to tell you
guys a little bit about my background
the things that are in it and why the
there and why they're important to me so
pretty soon I'm going to be doing a
video just about that I'm going to show
you just about everything behind me and
what it means and why it's there and as
I said why it's important to me I hope
you enjoy that video thanks as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my next
[Music]